تقول موسكو إن لقاح سبوتنيك سيتم
اختباره على 40000 شخص على الأقل
في خمس دول
بدءًا من الأسبوع المقبل
، والهدف هو تلبية
المعايير السريرية الدولية للمرحلة الثالثة
التي تم تسجيلها بالفعل للاستخدام
قبل تلك المرحلة الثالثة
تحدث المسؤولون الروس أيضًا إلى
سلامة لقاح الفاكتين
قائلين  إنه يستخدم نظام توصيل
مشابه للقاحات
المعتمدة
دوليًا بالفعل ضد فيروسات أخرى ، فلنقم بإحضار
كبير مراسلينا الطبيين إليزابيث
كوهين
من أتلانتا مع المزيد ، فما الذي يقوله
الخبراء وعلماء الأوبئة
حول ما
تروج له روسيا بشكل أساسي باعتباره لقاحًا
آمنًا يدخل مرحلة
حاسمة  مرحلة المحاكمة هنا
holla سأعطيك إجابة قصيرة جدًا من
الدكتور سكوت غوتليب ، وهو المفوض السابق
لإدارة الغذاء والدواء الأمريكية
،
قال إنني لن آخذه وأعتقد أن هذا يقول
كل
ما يقوله كل خبير  الذي
تحدث عن هذا علنًا قال
آه لا تضع هذا في داخلي ، فهم لم
يحن حقًا
في روسيا ، يبدو أنهم يقومون بأشياء
مختلفة قليلاً عما
تم القيام به في الولايات
المتحدة وفي أوروبا في الولايات المتحدة وأوروبا ،
تختبرها أولاً
من بين عشرات الآلاف من الأشخاص لمعرفة ما إذا
كانت آمنة
وفعالة  لا تطرحه في السوق ثم قم
بهذا النوع من الاختبار
ما هو الهدف من الاختبار إذا
كنت قد وضعته بالفعل في السوق
فأنت لا تحمي مواطنيك إذا
قمت بطرحه في السوق ثم قمت بعمل
كبير-  اختبار النطاق
ليس منطقيًا ، لن
أشمر عن سواعدي من أجله ،
فماذا عن ما أعنيه أن
ما يجادلون به هو أنه من
الآمن أخذ ذلك بشكل أساسي ،
فلماذا لا تأخذ هذا التمويل
أه أه نوع من
ممول الجهد أه كان أه على CNN آه
في الساعة الماضية قائلاً حسنًا ،
لقد أخذها والداي أيضًا
وأولادي ثم نجري التجربة لاحقًا ، أعني
أعتقد أن وجهة نظرهم هي
ما لديك  أن تخسر لديك الكثير
لتخسره ، فأنت تعلم
أنه آسف ، يجب أن أضحك فقط لأنك
هذا ما كان الأمريكيون
والروس يتعاملون معه
عندما تستمع إلى بوتين أو تستمع
إلى ترامب هو أنهم يقولون صدقوني
فقط صدقوني ، إنه لأمر رائع هذا ما
قاله ترامب عن هيدروكسي كلوروكوين
وأنت تعرف ما هي الدراسات
التي تظهر أن هيدروكسي كلوروكين يؤذي بعض
الناس هناك  هو سبب في أننا نختبر
الأشياء
أولاً وقبل كل شيء يقولون بوتين وما إلى ذلك ،
يقولون إنه آمن ، كيف
نعرف أنه من المفترض أن نثق بهم إذا
أخبرتك أنني سأمنحك مليون
دولار هل تصدقني؟
صدقني بالطبع
لن ترغب في رؤية أن لديّ
مليون دولار في البنك أولاً ،
لذلك عندما يقول الروس يثقون بنا أنه
آمن ،
فإن الاستجابة العلمية هي أين
تظهر البيانات لنا البيانات بأنها آمنة وهم
ملاذون "  لقد أجروا الدراسة على عشرات
الآلاف من الأشخاص ، لذا فهم لا يعرفون
أنها آمنة
ربما قاموا بها في عشرات
الأشخاص أو ربما بضع مئات من
الأشخاص
ووجدوا أنها آمنة إذا كان
هذا صحيحًا حيث  تظهر البيانات
لي أن البيانات تظهر لي أن الدراسة توضح
لي
الأرقام وليس فقط أي أرقام ولكن الأرقام
التي تمت مراجعتها من قبل الأقران من
قبل علماء خارجيين لم يظهروا
لنا أي شيء ، كل ما قالوه هو
ثق بي أنها تبدو جيدة
دعنا نتحدث قليلاً عن
تجارب التحدي بالطريقة التي يتم بها إجراء التجارب الآن
هذه ليست تجارب تحدي في الوقت الحالي
نحن نجند أشخاصًا ليأتوا
للحصول على حقنة
ثم يذهبون لعيش حياتهم
وربما يواجهون  الفيروس في
حياتهم اليومية وربما لم يفعلوا
في تجربة التحدي ، فأنت تفعل
شيئًا مختلفًا تمامًا ،
ما تفعله هو تطعيم شخص ما
بلقاح تجريبي
ثم تضع الفيروس عن قصد
في
أنفه وبهذه الطريقة ترى ما إذا كان اللقاح
يعمل  من الواضح أنها
طريقة مباشرة جدًا للقيام بذلك ، حيث كان هناك
عدد قليل من الأصوات التي تدعو إلى
إجراء تجارب تحدي في الولايات المتحدة ولكن بصراحة
لم يكن
الكثيرون
قد جعلتها معاهد الصحة الوطنية
من الواضح جدًا أننا لا نجري تجارب تحدي في الولايات المتحدة ، ولكن إليكم الأخبار التي تتعاقد معها شركة نيه للتعاقد مع الشركة لصنع سلالة من الفيروس يمكن استخدامها في تجارب التحدي ، أخبرني الدكتور فوسي أن هذا هو خطة طوارئ أولية للغاية ، لا يعتقد أننا سنستخدم هذا أبدًا ، فهو لا يعتقد أننا سنقوم أبدًا بتجارب التحدي لكنه قال انظر أنه كان هناك الكثير من الضغط للاستعداد لهذه التجارب ، فلماذا لا نخلق قم بإلصاقها في الفريزر ، ولا نعتقد أننا سنحتاجها على الإطلاق إلى اختراق محتمل في مكافحة جائحة covid19 ، حيث تمنح إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير (FDA) إذنًا باستخدام الطوارئ لاختبار اللعاب ، ولا تحتاج إلى نفس الكواشف والمسحات التي كانت الخطوة المقيدة للمعدل لتكون قادرًا على إنشاء اختبار على نطاق واسع في هذا البلد ، فقد يكون حقًا مغيرًا لقواعد اللعبة إذا تمكنا من نشرها يقول المسؤولون إنه يمكن تحديد النتائج في أقل من ثلاث ساعات والاختبارات المتوقعة  تكلف حوالي 10
دولارات لكل عينة ،
أعتقد أن الأمر سيستغرق أسابيع إن لم يكن
أطول حتى يصبح هذا الاختبار
متاحًا على نطاق واسع ، ولكن عندما يتم توفيره
عبر الإنترنت ،
أعتقد أن الناس سيحبونه بشكل أفضل
بكثير من
اختبار مسحة الأنف الأكثر تدخلاً الذي ساعده الاتحاد الوطني لكرة السلة
لتمويل
تطوير هذا الاختبار
واستخدامه لاختبار الحاملات غير المصحوبة بأعراض ،
يأتي إعلان إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير هذا في الوقت الذي يتجاوز فيه
عدد القتلى الأمريكيين لحالات covet 19 المعروفة 170.000
وفقًا لجامعة جونز
هوبكنز ،
لا يزال هذا الفيروس ينتشر على نطاق واسع في
المجتمعات.  تحت السيطرة حتى الآن على معظم
الولايات المتحدة
، أخشى ، وعلى الرغم من عدم وجود حالات جديدة من كوفيد 19
تتجه نحو الانخفاض ،
يقول البعض إن المزيد لا يزال يتعين القيام به ،
فقد استثمرنا حقًا بأقل من
اللازم في الصحة العامة لعقود حتى
الآن واستمرنا في القيام بذلك خلال  هذه
الفترة بأكملها ولم أقم بالعمل
اللازم لاحتواء الفيروس أنا جون
لورانس أبلغ عن